another
reality of the
covet 19 pandemic is how it's going to
affect the draft the draft is going
forward it doesn't matter what we or
anyone else say the draft is happening
for a variety of reasons now the
challenge is how do you make the
selection process mesh with the
requirements
that are in place for
39 states and rising to stay at home
shelter in place only leave your home
for essential purposes and chris one
thing that
i recognized last night with a nudge
from somebody who was paying closer
attention to it than i was
when the nfl says we're going to allow
small gatherings of up to 10
for these mini war rooms for the draft
that's not going to fly in some of these
states if not all of these states where
the order is stay at home except for
essential purposes and those states
would very likely say it's not essential
for you to go get together in a group of
ten you can do it from home you don't
need to leave the house to go to some
location to have your draft war room and
i don't know the nfl is paying attention
to that issue and it may be that at the
end of the day the nfl has to backtrack
on it and say we can't do this because
if we can't if we can't do it in every
state that has a stay-at-home order then
it creates an unfair advantage for the
teams that can do it and i think
ultimately there's a chance they're just
going to pull the plug and say sorry you
can't you can't gather anywhere you're
going to have to do the draft entirely
from home everybody's going to have to
be at home you cannot leave your house
to go somewhere to get together with
even a group of two or three people
well first off i mean the states that
don't have the stay at home order like i
want to just say what what you are going
to take 49 states for us to see this
issue and then the 50th states finally
to go you know we didn't do the
stay-at-home order and everything
exploded like come on america what are
we doing like i just i don't understand
it you know all those spring breakers
that were down in florida they have
traveled back to their homes all over
the country so we got to worry about
that too but i'm with you and then this
is again an example mike of where the
nfl needs to be careful and they need to
show leadership to society in these type
of moments and if we're still here at
draft time and we're still in the kind
of the current state we are right now
where we're social distancing and not
that many people are allowed to gather
in one place then they need to
set the right example and not do that
added to the fact mike as you know and
you just said it you know you don't need
10 people in the war room for the draft
i mean at the end of the day you need
the owner the gm the head coach
the director of pro personnel and maybe
your head college scout everybody else
okay can call in or video conference and
i'm not even sure you need all five of
those guys you could probably just get
away with the owner the head coach and
the gm and have the other guys call in
too so that to me if that's where we're
at at that point you know the nfl needs
to be careful and make sure they do the
right thing and how it looks on the
optics and set a good example
how it looks is the key chris you said
the key words how it looks because it's
not going to look as good if everyone is
at home and it's all on zoom or face
time and they're connecting that way and
that's what gets shown on tv they still
want to be able to show
gatherings of jerry jones and stephen
jones and mike mccarthy
you know passing a phone around to the
to the as they're talking to the guy
that they make their first round pick
they want it to look normal in that way
it's not going to look normal in that
way not if the nfl properly complies
with the requirements of the states
where the stay-at-home order is in place
and and it sends a bad message to the
rest of us if the nfl is going to try to
try to twist and warp the rules to
justify having these war rooms in the
states with stay-at-home orders you know
we all should be complying to these
rules to the letter we shouldn't be
leaving the home for any reason that
truly isn't essential and uh i'm just
i have a feeling this one isn't over and
it's got three weeks to play out i think
by the time it's all said and done
everybody's going to be required to be
at home for the draft the coaches at
home the gm's at home everyone at home
okay well what if what if they found
some way to you know test everybody you
know two days before the draft and they
kind of kept them quarantined in the
facility if it was four or five people
and just say hey you know we've tested
you you're here now you gotta stay here
we're not letting you involved with
society and we'll see where it goes i
mean could they pull something like that
off
you're gonna have to take it up with 39
different uh states or at least the 22
states where the nfl does business and
make sure that it doesn't violate the
stay-at-home order to put those people
in the same place so there's there's a
lot of elbow grease they're gonna have
to put in to make this work and make it
mesh and i don't know that that issue's
on their radar screen well if it wasn't
it is now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports